normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government the
New York Times Are black voters leaving
Democrats behind they say polls suggest
they might be well we looked at an NBC
poll that I think showed Trump with 24%
of the black vote and if that's true
according to the Wall Street Journal
several years ago they wrote an article
in like 2018 that said that if Democrats
can't maintain uh 80% if Republicans
ever get more than 20 the Democrats are
they can't win at all so I'm not sure I
believe these things right there's been
a lot of conservative personalities said
you are insane to think black voters are
are going to move towards Trump in any
way the New York Times asks the question
and then the New York Post runs this
story Trump poll uh lead uh Trump
polling lead expands with Biden losing
Black and Hispanic support so I'm
wondering if it's not so much that Trump
is gaining but that because Biden is
losing it it results in a vote vacuum
mhm you don't need to vote for Trump if
you're not voting Trump is still going
to create a gap by
having people not vote for Joe Biden
right yeah I think that's happen people
are realizing I saw a lot of people this
weekend I forget what it was but people
realizing that they had life better
underneath the Trump underneath Trump
and they have under Biden think simple
as that they say Biden's lead among
Hispanic voters is now 3% down from 14
in an Emerson poll last November wow 11
points shift they say Biden's lead lead
among African-Americans was still
substantial 47 but down 15 points and
then there was that uh that poll in New
York Biden is up 10 points in a d plus
27 he's only up 10 wow Trump's also New
York you know there's a lot of people in
New York who who still love Trump and
who understood Trump before a lot of the
country did because if you're from New
York you know the certain type of
character that Trump was know this guy
he's he's not all of these things he's
he's this big bombastic right kid from
Queens he wasn't shocking to us no you
know when we saw him but for a lot of
the country it was like wa what is this
the New York Times is saying Trump's
lead uh his support among black voters
is
22% so up several points they say in
2020 Biden defeated Trump by 4.5 in the
popular vote though he won by much
narrower margins in the swing states
that saw him uh now look I think it's
ultimately I wonder why we even talk
about this stuff a year out that's the
thing so much is going to change the uh
if for example
Ronda santis wins in Iowa which there's
a very strong likelihood that he will
he's he's locked up 30,000 Precinct or
uh and he's working real hard chairs
he's working real hard
y then from January 15th through super
Tuesday anything can happen just
anything can happen and particularly in
an election where going into the spring
all of Trump's legal problems catch up
with him yeah that's true and we I mean
so among the many things that can happen
we could be running someone from jail I
that is not that is not an impossible
scenario given how how upside down Topsy
tury the world is now uh a and certainly
not constitutionally prohibited
either my view of this I I borrow this
from my friend Alan estren over at
Prager U uh he he points out that
narrative is an actual force in the
universe sort of like gravity it's not
narrative isn't something that we do
it's something that we observe and if
you go by that theory then at a minimum
the story belongs to Donald Trump it is
Donald Trump's story it doesn't mean he
wins the election uh but I don't think
people are ready we haven't gotten to
the end of the Donald Trump story yet
and people want to know what the end of
the Donald Trump story is more than they
want to know what the next story is so
true I love narrative you can feel it it
is a substance in Carl Benjamin made
this point to me he did this is like a
year and a half ago I was saying I
thought DeSantis was the was the the
right choice um he had a better
temperament proven leadership not that
Trump you know didn't but Trump's
temperament wasn't there and then Carl
messaged me saying Trump's Arc is not
done Trump's story must be completed he
made a video about it and now things
have shifted so you think even with
Trump's legal problems This lends itself
to Trump winning and or or at least very
well being the nominee and and making it
to November well whether he's the
nominee or not I think that maybe he
takes the entire Republican party down
like maybe for example Ronda santis wins
Iowa he gets a big boost going into
South Carolina he somehow gets past
Nikki Haley there Ronda santis becomes
the nominee Donald Trump splits the
party and says he he won't back Ronda
santis Donald Trump uh loses the
election for Republicans or Des Santa
somehow wins and pardons Donald Trump
and it's the greatest you what whatever
it is it's like whatever the craziest
thing we can imagine somehow the Donald
Trump story still hasn't ended the most
likely outcome is the most uh
entertaining is that what Elon says yes
most likely outcome is it's going to end
with Trump outside the White House
jumping midair then Freeze Frame we just
back to normal I mean fair point I mean
but really if you think about it Trump's
story arc can end in a lot of really
crazy ways oh yeah for sure they're not
all good right right like January 6
nobody saw coming imagine January 6times
10 with an angry Donald Trump and some
whatever histor Arch becomes now I guess
the difference there is Trump was
actually president when January 6
going he could done a lot of he not now
he's not there's a lot of things he do
and so just but weird things can my my
bigger concern is probably his story
could end rather unceremoniously through
health issues oh
yeah yeah I mean in in in in both the uh
uh uh uh external and internal certainly
someone could hurt himh or he could
quite literally just at
77 you know be shuffled loose the Mortal
coil what I'm worried about is like
we've been witnessing absurdity like
exponentially grow every year over the
past few years what is next year's
October surprise going to be it's going
to be so terrifying and absurd you know
like or I'm also you know they've been
dropping these hints lately about the
internet apocalypse you know because
solar flares right right is that going
to happen like are we not going to be
able to talk and communicate anymore I
keep wondering about that and I'm like
you know we really should have kept up
with the United States Postal Service
you know I want to entertain that
possibility cuz just imagine this
scenario it's a week before the election
and solar flare internet is cut out
internet's gone and the only thing
available now is radio and terrestrial
television so we're radio and so what
happens is you've got no internet
industry is collapsed but you turn the
TV on and there's your good friend Wolf
Blitzer letting you know that Joe Biden
won trust him oh that's it well wouldn't
it be nice if we had paper ballots
before the solar flare takes out the
grid that would be so nice they had
paper ballots in Argentina we need to
push that how long did it take him to
count those votes two three months I
think it was just one I think it was
just the one day no one day impossible
understand the one day I know I think
they were you know even
just just went they may try to turn off
the country and turn it back on again
internet goes down just in time for the
election and yeah nobody can communicate
nobody can organize they did essentially
do that in 2020 they basically shut down
the world and then and then tried to
turn it back on again and we still wow
we've come nowhere near the end of the
consequences that's czy and back then as
terrible as that was we could still
subvert their narrative because we could
communicate through the internet they
know now they got to get rid of that so
we can't subvert them so we have to make
ham radios and homing pigeons some way
to communicate Hami let's do it you got
take our bank accounts money Tim ham
doesn't sound very good I don't know
that might be well no we want we want
ham internet yeah I know so data
transmission through ham which is
ridiculously slow
Hamet I like it you're you're better off
just talking yeah on the street go go
outside and Shout that's yeah but
seriously imag just actually imagine
what it would be like if it was three
days before the election and there's no
internet at all and we all are old
enough to remember life before the
internet yeah there a lot of young
people who do not oh yeah it's glorious
in many ways you know actually it's kind
of crazy to think about like a like
there's 20-year-olds who do not know
life without access to the internet
there are younger children man it's it's
2023 so a kid born in two in 200 let's
let's be realistic born in 200 2000 you
are not old enough to understand life
and cell phones and internet by the time
you seven or eight cell phones are
ubiquitous yep by the time you're 13
everyone's got one y now you're 23 years
old you have never lived a moment
without instant access information cell
phone and there's never been a point at
which You've Lost That yeah you've gone
to dead zones you've been out at parties
in the desert where no connectivity but
you've never been in a city with no
internet right that's crazy that's where
that fracturing that we were talking
about earlier is going to take place you
know because those people at that age
they're in their identity online means
as much of them as their identity out
here exact which isy sad but like what
you were saying earlier hopefully
there's some people who realize they we
reject that we want real life we want a
family we're going to go to the
supermarket we want to see sad it is
necessary it's necessary to um you know
curate your online presence because
otherwise your online presence is going
to come back and get you fired from your
job yeah so you got to be careful of it
yeah yeah but I am seeing I do think
that more kids are kind of like of the
Gen Z and if I can use my you know just
this year teenage son as an example
they're much more interested in being
anonymous online they don't want to put
their names out there they don't even
necessarily want to put their faces out
there you know they want to be in person
with their friends and they want to have
whatever the curat thing but they don't
put as much stock in their identity
online they use it they do a lot of
jokes just trolling just a lot of that
stuff isn't that what hok wants to get
rid of in her I said my you know my son
I'm anti anonymity on the
internet to what agree because I think
it's it's appropriate for people to be
able to be anonymous uh for various
reasons but it's also I think it's weak
for people too especially if you go
after people I don't think that
it's here's the
problem the problem is that anonymity on
the internet allows for the ghettoizing
of beliefs that are not approved by the
regime so a lot of people will say well
I have to be I have to be anonymous on
the internet because my boss finds out
that I've got these views they'll fire
me but you're only in the position where
your boss could fire you for finding out
about those views because you've allowed
those views to be completely ghettoised
through anonymity online if uh I
if five million people came out today
and said
uh the
nword I'm not recommending it but no one
would ever get fired for saying the
nword again thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net